we got one advantage he's coming to us
[Music]
we've been fans living this character
since we were kids since the very first
Iron Man movie we fell in love with the
MCU and then just to be able to tell a
story in Winter Soldier carried that
through the Civil War and now to be able
to carry it through to infinity war and
Beyond has been like an incredible
opportunity for Joe and I let's talk
about this plan here's I think it's good
except it sucks so let me do the plan
and that way it might be really good Wow
he did an intense amount of prep work on
the scripts the script is everything -
my brother and I we were working on both
scripts for Avengers three and four at
the same time it took a real discipline
focus effort - to get these stories
where we needed them to be obviously
we're dealing with as many characters
you could possibly put in one movie we
involved cast in the process because
they know their characters better than
anybody so we get great insight from
them so really that all the prep for us
was was focusing on script whatever
actors will you know off rust more money
gets the most amount of screen time and
that's how he ends up balancing it out
know we spent many many many months with
the writers Marcus McFeely
in a room thinking about all of the
characters we basically started the
process of this movie with pictures of
all the characters we'd hang them all
around the room and we've just spent
months thinking about where we could
take each character how do we combine
into character what are the stories that
sort of smash these characters into one
another it's a very long story telling
process that we go through but it's
really it's a really fun on it creative
bone tell me who's name again Danis
you
[Music]